this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for the introduction
so it's my pleasure to present the
research that has been going in my group
for the last three years and so my lab
is focusing on water stress related
issues to agriculture so in here you've
got an overview of all kinds of issues
that are pestering the modern
Agriculture and most of the issues that
are related to water stress either there
is too much of water or too little of
water or the water is salty are
presented by the blue dogs so you can
see that there are quite a lot of blue
dots
um and how can we the water is becoming
a hot commodity in the current climate
especially fresh water so how can we
manage that the that the agriculture is
going to be providing us with food
Security in a sustainable way so we can
one of that is diversify our agriculture
learn as much from the species that are
already tolerant to those extreme
conditions and here is don't be fooled
by my Photoshop skills here is a here's
a desert rose that is native to a very
dry island of Yemen
growing some some edible fruits but then
another way that we can ensure to Future
proof our agricultural system is to look
into the intra-specific variation like
forward genetic studies species that are
that are already that were that are
already adapted within our agriculture
like tomatoes wheat barley look at all
of the land races and all of the
cultural important materials and how can
explore the tolerance within those lines
to see how can we Implement those stress
tolerance mechanisms into the into the
germplasm that is being grown on the big
big scale
and so we're exploring within my lab
we're exploring water stress resilience
across multiple species we're of course
using arabidopsis paleana which is the
crop of knowledge and we're using the
wild tomato which is the close relative
to a cultivated tomato we're also using
peppery Bean which is a close relative
to a common Bean a fasciotis and I'm not
really going to talk too much about that
ribbing because of time constraints and
we're also using cowpe which is a vigna
Kopi has been an incred incredibly
important crop in the U.S agriculture at
the beginning of the last century but
since the introduction of soy it it's
it's called its contribution to the
agriculture has diminished nevertheless
it is still serving as a very important
cover crop
um and then going before I kind of go
and explore all of the things that we're
doing this is kind of the discovery
pipeline that we're applying with in my
lab so working on all kinds of
architectural trades is complicated
because you can especially in the
context of natural diversity panels you
cannot really look at the relation
between your phenotype of interest and
the overall yield because natural
diversity panels are different for many
different reasons so those are not
mutant studies so what we're doing is
we're saying we have a trait of trading
press or a theme of Interest so fiend is
kind of like an atomic value of a
phenotype
phenotype is the same relationship too
as a gene to a genotype so it's a very
very Atomic thing so rather than how I'm
looking today so this is my phenotype
but the specific fin is the length of my
hair or a color of my eyes stuff like
that right so we're selecting a field of
interest that we think is contributing
to the plant performance we look at what
is the plasticity in response to stress
that's kind of the things that we're
interested in of course we're looking at
the heritability because if your feeling
is not heritable and in our specific
case we're not going to find underlying
genetic mechanisms then we're going into
population screening so we're doing
phenotyping sometimes it's high
throughput sometimes it's high
dedication and then we're doing forward
genetics
uh once we we've done the four genetics
we have identified few genes of interest
uh and then we're doing the validation
using reversion ethics which is making
transgenic plans gain of function loss
of function and identify identify their
molecular context and only at this stage
are we looking at the relationship with
overall plant tolerance to stress and
overall relationship to yield because
that's we're comparing the wild type to
our gain or loss of function mutants but
and those those plants are really
differing only hopefully in the field of
interest in the gene of interest and not
in all kinds of things that are also
affecting the yield
so first is the arabidopsis so I started
with my with arabidopsis during my PhD
in Amsterdam and when you're exposing
the plans to increasing concentrations
of salt stress they are becoming smaller
my question is are they also becoming
any different are they changes salt
stress induced changes in the plant
architecture so we developed some very
simple models to describe the root
system architecture as three components
this is all published where we identify
that yes salt is not only slowing down
the development of the roots but
actively changing the architecture of
the plant of the roots then of course we
put it into the into the GEOS we
screened 350 accessions of aerobic
offices this population as you can see
is extremely eurocentric because people
that have collected this arabidopsis
have been making a lot of research in
Europe and collecting the plants around
Europe and since then that was done in
2004 since then we have also collected
arabidopsis all over the world including
Africa and Saudi Arabia where I did my
postdoc
um so after starting my postdoc I as I
was a root biologist and I'm a very
proud person to be a root biologist
because it's root biologists we're
looking at the hidden half of the plants
but it's still a half
so after doing all of the all of the
study on the salt induced changes in a
root system architecture we're starting
to look at what is the what is the salt
induced changes to root and shoot ratio
and we know that root to shoot ratio is
extremely important when it comes to
Drought so plants are prioritizing
Scavenging for water and minimizing the
transpiration so the route to shoot
ratio is changing in response to Drought
how is it changing in response to salt
and so we thought you know I had all of
those scanned agar plates for my PhD
might as well reuse the images so
together with Rasheed and house we
developed a very simple tool that is
basically isolating green pixels white
pixels in the blue pixels for the root
shoot and the background
and we Quantified
semi-manually or semi-automatically but
semi-automatic always means semi-manual
someone has to do all of this work and
you only realize it when you're doing it
uh so we Quantified all of those pixels
of course we have problems with this too
because if the plants are growing into
each other we cannot really separate the
roots
so it's not it's not a perfect tool
anyway let's go let's cut the chase go
to the results I mean here we've got the
growth rate of roots and shoots under
control conditions salts more sold so
unsurprisingly the more salt you add the
slower the root is going to grow and the
slower the shoot is going to grow
not a big not a big surprise over there
but what happens when we look at the
route to shoot ratio so under control
conditions we see that the root of
situation is around one which means that
the growth of the root and the shoot is
fairly well coordinated as soon as you
add salt
we can see that this variation is
starting to spread in both directions
which means that the root and the shoot
coordination is kind of disturbed so
some of the plants are becoming rootier
some of them are becoming shootier and
we cannot really find a big threat Trend
if whether shootier or Routier trend is
overall better for salt stress tolerance
so what we did is we threw all of this
data into genome-wide Association when
you do genome Association this is the
kind of results you're getting so in
here on the x-axis we've got five
chromosomes of arabidopsis with all of
the positions of the Snips and here
we've got an association strength and if
you're a trade and in our our case
shoots over total area of the seedling
at high fault stress concentration is
associated with any specific genetic
loci you can see that your Association
strength is going up right
so in here we've got up we've got a
couple of snips then we got a new data
set of the snip being released so this
is the genome Association level with
only 250 000. here's the genome
association with four million Snips so
we've got much higher resolution but
also your threshold for significance is
going up because we need to do a bomb
for running threshold so the more things
you're testing the lower p-value
actually are chasable so it's not
significant but it was significant
before so let's
significant Snips are here in red in
this Gene called tough 247 and it's
laboring all of the other adoption for
seven it's like tough two for seven
Valley
what does dove247 stands for it stands
for domain of unknown function thank you
very much
so then with the with all of the
increased Snips we're mapping all of the
Snips are mapping to this one dot two
four seven let's relax okay great this
is this is fantastic but what does daf
do so we're looking at available
expression data it goes up on result
stress but it's relatively at the very
short uh short term and then it goes
down again it doesn't it doesn't seem to
be super specific to other stresses like
drought or osmotic osmotic a little bit
no but not too cold or anything else
so
um what we did is we looked for the
mutants so loss of function
um mutants and that's all of the data
done by Mariam who is here in the
audience uh so she was doing a lot of
high dedication phenotyping or group
system architecture of plants growing
under control conditions sold and more
sold and what she found is that
we see a slower development of the
lateral rules of the gulf mutants at the
low salt conditions but we don't see a
significant effect on their household
conditions and we don't see any effect
under no stress conditions which is nice
so we see something is happening with
this lateral root development
okay so then we say like okay is this
effect only specific to other plates
because other plates although they are
native Native environment for
arabidopsis they're not exactly native
environment for many plants so we wanted
to grow them in the soil so we're using
the system that we have developed at the
bti called the phenocage so you've got
arabidopsis plants growing under the
Raspberry Pi camera and we're making
images every 30 minutes which allows
that allows us to track the growth rate
so what Mariam did again is she grew the
plants Colombia and the mutants under
control conditions after early stress so
the stress was applied to two weeks
after germination and late stress and
the stress was applied later on three
weeks after generation and after early
stress we start seeing that the Colombia
and the dark and the duck is actually
growing much better compared to the
Colombian so the mutants although it
developed less flat Roots it's
performing better under soil conditions
with salt stress we don't see much
difference under no stress conditions
again so we also had a look at okay do
we see any differences in the shoot iron
leakage so iron leakage is an essay that
we're doing to see what is the cell
integrity and if your your plant is very
healthy you have very little ion leakage
and salt stress typically tends to
induce iron leakage as you've seen here
in Colombia so we see in here that the
dove is actually experiencing less iron
liquid
and we also measured the sodium
accumulation in the rosettes and again
Duff so after salt stress we're seeing
increased accumulation of salt stress of
salt iron sorry and then the dove mutant
has a slightly lower accumulation of Eye
of sodium Islands which is quite
interesting and and it's in line with
like they perform better therefore they
have less damage and they accumulate
less sodium all adds up
um
another thing so kind of going back to
the Natural variation what I like to do
whenever I find a gene that is
associated with a specific
um specific trait we find the gene but
then like what is the natural variation
that is actually causal to that specific
phenotype because natural variation is
not that there are accessions where the
gene is non-functional or dysfunctional
but it could be functional but slightly
differently so what I do is I put all of
the Snips that are within the gene
coding body of my Gene and I'm trying to
do the haplotype analysis so I'm rather
than with GEOS we're doing it for a snip
every snip we're kind of splitting a
population into is that specific snip
significantly different from our control
group with haplotype analysis we're kind
of taking multiple Snips together so
it's kind of like we're making words
rather than letters so a specific snip
combination and our heart impact one is
where the Colombia is our reference
genotype and half of the type 11 was
another set of juice and every single
haplotype needs to be represented by at
least three different accessions why
three because you cannot make a box plot
with less than three points
so we found uh this haplo type 11 had
was significantly shootier compared to
Colombia under salt stress so we're like
okay well let's start cloning those
genes and seeing like what is actually
the variation rather than the snips so
once we started cloning it together with
martial that was back at the house
Michelle was very concerned because all
of the sequencing results from the
Hubble pipe 11 came up with those huge
gaps and it turns out all of the
accessions that were belonging to happen
type 11 had two 200 base per insertions
which led to a premature stop coder so
daft247 domain of unknown function it's
still a domain and we have a predicted
transmembrane domain at the end of the
protein and we've got a domain of real
unknown function at the very beginning
so in the Colombia this is kind of the
predicted protein structure in that half
of 511 or accession dlh1 we've got this
kind of structure but it's predicated so
we still don't really know okay so that
kind of LED off to think okay what is
the function of all of those different
domains so
um multiple people have been involved in
cloning of all of the different
constructs so we've got Toyota we've got
Rita and Mariam finally had all of the
constructs in her hands uh to to examine
what is the pro the protein localization
within the uh within tobacco transient
Leaf transformation so we chopped so
this is the sequence of all of the
protein we've got the nuclear
localization signal in here we've got a
coiled call domain and here here we've
got the costume binding domain and
here's the transplant Vector so we
basically split oh yeah and here this y
this is where the premature stop codon
is in our in our blh-1 accessory so
basically what we split is we split the
session for this first domain so this is
our fragment a this is our fragment B
all the way to transmembrane domain it's
our frequency so the full length protein
it seems like it's localizing to a
plasma membrane whenever we look only at
the a b domain so we chop off the
transmembrane domain its localization is
really translocated from predominantly
in the cell nucleus
however if we only look at the Domain a
or domain B we've got still much more
nuclear localization but it's we see
also a cytoplasmic localization in those
in those things as well so it seems like
the
transmembrane domain is really kind of
holding the protein at the plasma
membrane and once that's chopped off by
whatever something it's translocating
into the nucleus and possibly binding it
we have done a yeast to hybrid screen
and the only protein that came up is
another enough
so that's fine
um
and we also have looked at what are the
proteins that might be possibly
regulating the duff expression upstream
and Mariam has digged deeply deeply into
the architecture into the literature and
she found that a verkey 20 no 75 is
possibly regulating it we have done some
preliminary essays with whether that
whether we see a Duff expression in the
working mutant we don't it's totally
wiped out which is nice but we're doing
more essays to kind of confirm the
molecular context of the duff so far
another thing
that we have done is look that's where
the duff promote is actually expressed
so that promotes a hearing good seedling
ground under control condition salt
stress and we see that it's really
expressed predominantly in the in the
cell cells so Stell is where all of the
the region around the vasculature right
and
um Mariam also looked at the expression
the older Leaf tissues we don't see it
being we only see a slight expression in
young leaves but then the older the
leaves are getting the lower the dafa
expression is and we don't see any
expression in the pollen which is
interesting because some of the other
247 genes were involved in like
autoimmunity outer sterility issues
we also have looked at Quantified the
signal of the gas throughout the roots
uh in response to salt and we're seeing
that there are some
some highlights whatever the lateral
roots are coming up
and we're seeing that when we quantify
all of these gust signals we see that
the signal on their salt stress is
higher significantly higher compared to
the control conditions so the promoter
activity is enhanced by salt stress
and this localization in the cell so
Stell is the region where a lot of
signals are coming for the supervisation
of the of the supervisation in terms of
salt stress is extremely important
because it forms this hydrophobic layer
which prevents water loss but also ion
entry into the root which is like well
in all of those phenotypes that we're
seeing like the duff mutants are having
lower accumulation of salt lower
cellular damage it all makes sense so
let's have a look if we see changes in
the root supervisation so here we've got
Colombia under control conditions and
salt stress and you can see that the
salt by itself is already inducing the
root supervisation and then the dot
mutants which we see in here on those
semi-quantitative pictures from the
confocal microscopy that Mario did is
we're seeing that the dot overall is
having a slightly higher intensity when
it comes to the superint staying we also
quantify that in collaboration with
Georgian brakaki from the University of
Davis and and we found that some of the
components of sugaring like totopati uh
fatty fatty alcohols are induced in the
dark mutants compared to the Colombia
especially in Seoul but some of them are
also induced under control conditions
which is fun
um so the dove story thus far we know
that the duff 247 our specific stuff 2.7
is expressed during early vegetative
stages of development
we know that the full length stuff is
residing in the plasma membrane and once
we chop off the transmembrane domain it
relocates to nucleus it does something
there we don't know yet what
um Duff seems to be limiting salt
tolerance so if you don't have the duff
you're better off when you're when
you're experiencing salt stress and and
it's probably through negative
regulation of apoplastic root barriers
and right now we're developing the rnai
and over-expressionalized in arabidopsis
that are targeting multiple dots to
evaluate like whether we knock out our
Duff only or multiple doves at the same
time do we see a Compound Effect
um
and I I told you that we identified one
interactor of that through yeast to
hybrid but it didn't provide us much
Clarity
um okay so moving on we're also
investigating other plants as I told you
so arabidopsis is only one part of the
lab we're investigating wild tomato
which is native to South America in here
which spans a range of different planets
including Galapagos Islands so those are
the one of the two together with cheese
man in galapagency pimpinellifolium on
one of those tomatoes that are you know
um described as growing into the sea
breeze and being extremely tolerant and
peppery Bean is another species that we
started to work on which is native to
Southwest of U.S and Northern Mexico it
has been used in Native agriculture for
quite some time right now and we're very
thankful to kind of explore more of
those of this of this germplasm and
another species of interest is cow pee
which is native to sub-Saharan Africa
and it has been grown by subsistence
Farmers under non-irrigated conditions
uh which is you know relying on whatever
is falling from the sky which is
sometimes not so much
um so Pimpin telephonium is the closest
relative to cultivated tomato and it is
it has been previously used to integrate
some of the traits into a cultivated
tomato like the stemless gene or
resilience to many many viruses and
biotic stresses it's native to dry and
coastal regions of Peru Ecuador and
Galapagos it has high salinity drought
and heat tolerance we've got the
reference genome sequence available that
has been done by bti by face lab and and
we have uh sequenced 230 accessions at
Coast
um and with phenotypes in the field
conditions and in the plant accelerator
so under control Greenhouse conditions
in Australia and the paper has just been
accepted from the bio archive so you can
go and check out if you're interested in
more details
um so me being myself I of course screen
the whole population for different
system architecture so here we've got
we're only growing one plant per plate
in here because the tomato has
tremendous root system architecture
we're growing them under control
conditions and salt and of course later
on it follows with high dedication root
phenotyping and it was done during the
pandemic by myself and Haley who is a
technician in my lab so here are the
results basically so we're looking at
here at the main root growth the lateral
root increase and the lateral root grows
under control blue and salt stress
conditions and you can see that main
root growth is actually not that much
affected in the solanumanifolium
population but the number of flats it is
and the lateral length also not so much
if you look at the overall population
levels however if you compare individual
plants how they are reacting under
control and salt stress we can start
seeing that there is definitely a
genotype specificity effect on over
there for all of the trip almost all of
the tricks for the average natural
treatment links not so much
however if we look at the relative
performance of the plants so are there
changes are there different strategies
for different accessions in terms of
social tolerance we see that there is
also different patterns so for example
we see plants that are not really phased
by salt in terms of main root growth but
they are really suffering when it comes
to lateral root development and we see
of course other
opposite patterns like they are very
much sensitive in their main regrowth
and not so much when it comes to lateral
development so kind of basing based on
that we selected
one accession uh of taking daily volume
which is m248 which develops a high
number of latch routes but those flat
roots are their length is very finite
and we also started screening a
cultivated population of tomato where
we've got exactly the opposite strategy
so both of those plants are so tolerant
but one is keeps on popping up new
lateral Roots the other one doesn't
really pop up new laterals but it
elongates whatever it has so we're like
hmm those are really interesting
opposing strategies is there anyone
better no there's not they're just as
tolerant if we cross them so Mariam has
crossed again Mariam is the is the hero
of the lab so she crossed both of those
lines with F1 we see that the the babies
are inheriting both of the positive
traits which is which means that there
is no negative trade-off which is great
so right now we did an F2 screen and
we're doing a box aggregate analysis so
we've got the plans that are superheroes
so they are both they keep on popping
new lateral roots and elongating them
they've got we've got the super losers
which are having problems with
elongation and popping of the new roots
and we've got the intermediates which
are similar to both of the patterns so
right now we just got back the sequences
for the Volkswagen of analysis and
hopefully we can put that book segregate
analysis on top of our genome
Association that we've got for the
lateral roots and see which of the
genetic loci are um are contributing to
the lateral root popping and lateral
root elongation under Soul stress and
hopefully there are different loci
however so we're not we're not finished
yet with tomato story because if you
spend a lot of time with your data what
I did during a pandemic you start seeing
things and sometimes those things are
real sometimes they are not real so uh
when I started drawing all of those
roots there are specific patterns that
keep kept on popping up and I started
seeing like all of the rules that were
looking exactly like an upside down
Christmas tree
something like a telephone pole so
you've got the straight root and all the
latinums are having very finite lengths
but they're all
getting out then we've got the little
droopy telephone call and then we've got
the broomstick so much majority of your
life roots are popping up at the root
base
Mac this is interesting but how do I
like you see something and like how do
we get it Quantified in actual stuff
that we can't like absolute number
average at root size branches own size
all of those things like canonical
trades that we're normally using for
describing fruits so I was like okay
maybe I can make some kind of mind map
because I see it and but I don't like I
always have one comparison between my
Christmas tree telephone pole droopy
telephone pole and Broomsticks there's
always one significant non-significant
comparison so how how do I get to
describe what I see in here with numbers
and then I start talking to
mathematicians and Argent Chandra secker
who is right now at Southwestern
University he was like we should use
Pareto front
because if we use the Pareto front
location we can see beautiful
differences between all of those
different idea types like great what is
separate the front
is a metric that people are using for
evaluation of infrastructures
um in the in the cities
so what you've got in here so here is an
um a subway system of Amsterdam which
has recently undergone an expansion that
costed the whole city millions of
dollars because they try to dig tunnels
on their very old buildings so every
single time that you're building a new
branch of your network is extremely
expensive similarly to the plant every
single time you're making a new route
you need to invest
some effort some some building blocks
into that so are you being and you can
be fast or cheap you cannot be cheap and
fast that doesn't exist
so if you look at the root system
architecture we've got main routes as a
kind of Highway it has to exist there
and you've got lateral roots that are
performing the most of the radial
transport of nutrients and water so
radio transport is we're absorbing water
from outside of the soil into the
vasculature and that goes up to support
the growth of the shoot right so there
are multiple ways of connecting those
root tips to the main route Highway
so we can if we abstract that so we've
gotten here the root as we see it let's
say we only know the position of the
lateral root tips and the main root
highway so we can connect it in a very
fast way we can connect it in a very
cheap way
or we can connect it in the intermediate
way so that means that you don't really
have one solution that is ideal you've
got a whole range of Ideal solution
right so you've got the front of Optimal
Solutions and we want to know how far or
where on this on this front of Optimal
Solutions we are so that kind of
determines our Christmas tree broomstick
or telephone pole right and then
so we've got here front Optimal
Solutions so the alpha is your location
on the front and then the other thing is
you can also say how what is the
distance to my front of Optimal
Solutions right because the plants are
having all of the other things that they
need to be doing
so when we look at the distance from the
parental front the plants that are
growing under Soul stress which are the
red lines and the plants that are
growing on the control conditions which
are blue lines you can see that the red
lines are significantly smaller So Soft
they have smaller distance from the
optimal front of solutions which means
that the plants are growing much more
efficient under stress
compared to whenever they are growing
under control conditions when there is
no stress which I can relate to when I'm
stressed I'm extremely efficient if I'm
not stressed I'm going around and yeah
doing all kinds of things
and when we looked at the Pareto front
location so this is the alpha so it's
whether you're a broomstick or a
telephone pole we see that the the the
data is much more noisier and that is
mainly because the system the Pareto
front location system is not exactly
developed for dynamic systems because
infrastructure in the city it is a
little bit Dynamic but not not so much
so
and the other the other point before I I
um go further is we put all of this data
into the G was the heritability is
surprisingly high so that's a great
thing and we are finding some of the
some of the associated genes so in here
we've got Tomatoes 12 chromosomes that's
why everybody's a little bit more colors
obviously but we're not following any of
those genes just yet because we need to
fix our model first
and we recently got an NSF uh
mathematical biology Grant to do that so
there are a couple of things so first of
all we need to expand the model to
accommodate lateral gravitropism so
right now all of the lateral root tips
are connected with the straight line to
the main route we're not having like
this this quadratic or exponential shape
integrated in our model the other thing
is that black root conductivity in terms
of water and nutrients is very different
from the main root conducted so if you
look at the cross sections that I did
for the grant is you see here the cross
section of the main route the blue bits
are where the silent vessels are and
here is the cross section of the
laterals so you can see that the blue
bits are much bigger in the main route
compared to the lateral root so you've
got the significant diff significantly
different kind of pipe that you have to
squeeze through the bigger your pipes
the faster you can go but we're not
integrating that in the model just yet
so we need to we need to make sure that
we integrate that across development to
access of the root but also
differentiating between the lateral
roots and the main fruit
and then we also found that together
with Mariam again we found that when we
are applying hormones to ours to Our
Roots we can significantly alter the
Pareto front location so in here we're
changing this broomstick to a telephone
pole by adding auxin and additionally
when we're adding oxen it is increasing
significantly increasing sodium
accumulation in Our Roots so
seemingly the the the
um
telephone call might not be the best
strategy when you want to limit the iron
accumulation in your uh in your route
and in your shoot so we're figuring that
one out as well and right now the trend
is an undergrad student that is working
in my lab and he has been working
meticulously through the summer making
the cross sections of different
developmental zones of the main route
and right now he's going to do all of
the different developmental zones of the
lateral Roots as well and once we've got
that we can put that into updated model
and all of the phenotyping is done so
that's great so we can recalculate our
Pareto front optimization and put that
in again into the genome Association and
identify underlying genes which is
really nice
so let's switch to another
oh okay let's switch to another crop
that we started to work on is copy so
copy as I already told you is native to
sub-Saharan Africa you can see in here
the natural diversity panel for copy has
already been developed by Maria Munoz
amatrian and a lot of people from the um
Nigeria is institutes for tropical
agriculture iita
um and they have already genotyped the
entire diversity panel for the global
diversity part of vocabi we also are
having collaboration with ahmadu Bello
University in Nigeria to genotype a
local Nigerian diversity plan and having
global and local diversity panels helps
because you've got a different
interference of population structure in
your photogenetic studies and so we've
got the reference genome we've got a
beautiful diversity panel
um so let's phenotype them
so
phenotyping Calgary is much more much
more difficult than phenotyping
arabidopsis first of all arabidopsis
grows like a pancake cowpe is growing
more like a human so we need to develop
tools to phenotype plants with complex
complex architecture so we went to
Lowe's we got some Woods together and we
met we
constructed in this pheno page so
basically it's a set of woods wooden
bits and here you've got the rotating
platform where you putting your plant on
the plant keeps on rotating and here
we've got a little Raspberry Pi camera
so camera keeps on flashing on the
plants and we've got seven different
side views of the plant so this is how
it looks like as the calc plant is
growing and we're isolating all of the
pixels that are belonging to the cowpe
from the background using a plant CV so
this is it is very automated because for
every single experiment we've got around
10 000 of images so you won't you don't
want to be doing that in a high
dedication way
um we looked at the correlation between
the shoot area that we're getting in
pixels and the fresh weight of the final
day of the experiments we've got a
beautiful high correlation probably as
well as for temporary beam because
peppery Bean is also growing weird like
in the 3D
and for
many different legumes because they've
got a different growth style so not all
of them are standing by themselves
you've got plans that are prostrate or
climbing so we need some kind of
structures to support them so what we
did is we 3D printed
um uh support structures those trellises
that you can see in here from the
transparent filament and they basically
disappear in the pictures and so we can
get quite a lot of uh a lot of precise
data for that and if you want to know
more again the the preprint is available
on the bio archive so uh send me an
email issue if you want more details on
that uh another thing that we also did
is we are also interested in like how
much pla how much water is a plant using
every single day and we're watering
especially in the drought stress we're
watering the plants to a specific Target
weight and
so watering them so before and after
watering all of the data is collected
and that allows us to estimate the
evapotranspiration of the plant so here
Olga Kolinski developed this
arduino-based system that is connected
to a pump and a scale and this is how it
looks in real life and we can track the
about the transpiration under control
conditions and drought stress you can
see that the plants are ever transpiring
much less this is quick and dirty data
of course it's much less precise than
all of the Leica or parameters and stuff
like that but it's still a data that
we've got for free
so we screened all of the 368 accessions
of copy we see that under stress
conditions they are growing slower not
surprisingly and we're seeing that the
transpiring also much less control
compared to the control conditions we
also measured some of the photosynthetic
traits using the handheld device
photosynqueue so to measure the quantity
meal the leaf temperature and put all of
that into the genome Association
and so in here we've got the genomic
Association plot so we'll put 11
chromosomes of healthy we found six I
think
six low side yes sixth loci for growth
rate cumulative of hyper transpiration
but not for the chemical energy and we
also looked so this is the association
strength this is the predicted effect
size graphs that we're using as well so
it's not only important that your
specific snip is significantly
associated with your trait but if you
predictively have a gain or loss of
function is it going to have an effect
that that you can care about at all so
this is what those crops are telling us
about so if our specific Snips like kind
of sticking out of the general
background noise it means that yes the
this this specific Association might be
worth exploring so right now making
transgenic plants in copy is extremely
difficult because they are not very easy
to transform so what we did is we looked
at homologous genes and arbitopsis we
ordered all of the tdma insertion lines
that were available and we screened it
in our in our different system that I
showed you earlier we see so with a
couple of genes that I'm not going to go
into detail they're all again described
in the bio archives paper
uh but for most of the most of the genes
that we found in arabiopsis The Knockout
or the tdna insertion is growing much
better than Colombia under drought
stress and we're seeing for some of them
also much better growth under control
conditions so it's really we're
targeting the Vigor of the plant rather
than drought specific responses which is
something that we don't mind really
um
one last thing that I wanted to tell you
about because this is this is extremely
exciting thing that we recently started
to explore so in collaboration with
buraf Mogi we explored what are the
stress-induced changes in the leaf
metabolism of palpi so we harvested the
samples at three days seven days and 14
days after drought in position in many
different accessions or three different
like sessions of color so you can see in
here that after three days we don't
really see much of the changes in the
vocabulary but as the time change as the
time goes on the metabolism is becoming
more and more different so those are the
PCA plots so just general Trends so the
more the longer you experience the
stress the more different the plants are
okay and then we of course looked at
specific metabolites such as Parolees
and stuff we saw all of those changes as
as we predicted but one of them
metabolites that was not very obvious
was an acetyl tryptophan and acetyl
tryptophan is
an acetylated form of tryptophan that's
all I know and the only thing that I
could find in the literature is that
it's enhancing the germination of one of
the orobranchi uh which is at uh
Striker plant I think uh so one of the
pathogen no parasitic plants uh that is
that is that is forming tremendous
losses in yield in Africa uh but we
haven't really had any
um
any any context for the Emma still
tryptophan and distress like abiotic
stress biology research so we saw that
this it's actually UCR 799 is showing
tremendous increase in nit whereas other
accessions less so when we look at
comparison of performance of those five
of those accessions so in here we've got
ucr799 growing on the drought stress we
see that this accession is actually
performing worse much worse compared to
suvita
and we see in here so that the the the
the gross friends are exactly the
opposite right so the more nit you seem
to accumulate the lower you grow so um
we ordered some of the NAT it was pretty
cheap so that's great and we put many
different concentrations that's the work
that was done this summer by an an Ru
undergrad Jade Milton so they what they
did is tested first different
concentrations of NAD on arabidopsis on
the plates and we see that lower
concentrations are enhancing the root
growth whereas higher concentration are
are decreasing the root growth which is
fine then we're like okay what happens
if we combine this Nat with with uh
osmotic stress so we use the peg 8000
and the more cosmotic stress you add the
slower your little growth but in
combination with nap the route seems to
be in performing slightly less
but not not by much
and we of course compared also the
effect of the NAT to control conditions
and also to tryptophan itself and auxin
at exactly the same
concentration so those are the results
that just got like earlier this week so
I didn't have time to quantify it yet
but you can see clearly that tryptophan
and an acetyl tryptophan are having
tremendously different effects from each
other so this an acetylation is really
having a huge huge difference and I also
didn't know that tryptophan is causing
this kind of effects on the root system
architecture so what do you know
um
so uh we also looked at the effect of an
acetyl tryptophan what happens when we
add an acetyl tryptophan to the plant's
growing in soil before I tried spraying
them because we found an acetyl
tryptophan in the leaves when I spray
them nothing happens when we add them to
the soil what we're starting to see is
this intervenol chlorosis which is
really interesting because normally
chlorus is occurring between the veins
but not from within the veins so there
is maybe some some kind of toxicity or
maybe some kind of nutrient deficiency
going on when we measure the chlorophyll
fluorescence we see that LV over FM
which is the light adapted Quantum yield
in the old leaves we've seen that NAD is
significantly decreasing the the
chlorophyll fluorescence or the quantum
yield of the leaves which is something
that you would expect and we're also
seeing that
chlorophyll content is decreased by the
NAT when we measured the specific
accumulation of elements in
collaboration with Miguel so we what
James did is they cut the leaf in the
edge the veins and the intervenal
regions and we measured all of the
different elements that we could measure
the only elements that we show and we
saw significant differences were nickel
so the NAT is causing increase in the
nickel but only in the edge not in the
vein not in the intravenal region we see
an increase in the phosphorus content we
see a tremendous increase in the sulfur
content and we see a tiny increase in
the copper content so if anyone has any
idea what this could be please let me
know
um
so then that's kind of wrapping up my
talk so take home messages is that
exploring the responses to stress we
focus on plant architecture rather than
just general plant size and might lead
you to discovery of new components of
resilience for example daf 247 and
studying stress resilience plans like
copy or wild tomato can provide new
strategies of quantifying the responses
to stress like the Pareto front
optimality that we that we observed and
dipping into untargeted metabolomics can
provide you with a lot of headache but
also potential new players in stress
resilience like an acetyl tryptophan and
with that I would like to thank you for
your attention for the opportunity to
present in front of such a distinguished
crowd of young and more experienced
researchers and of course all of my
collaborators all of the groups that I
have been a part of and I'm still a part
of in here thank you so much
this one
so I have a
I saw
plans
selected support
all my iPods uh
so my focus on die Cuts rather than
monocots is
uh I don't know I just and the the
legumes I think the monocots there's
quite a lot of interest in it because
there is a lot of agricultural interest
in it I think the monocots the die cuts
are are usually much more high value
fruits uh much much more richer in
different micronutrients micronutrients
and that's the main reason to kind of
like
help the communities that have not been
have had that much attention just yet
and trying to understand it on the
fundamental levels as well as develop
resources for the for the other
privileged communities
yes
yes they've got a very different room s
pipes
at Crown roads and they've got two
different types of flat fruits I don't
know how many different classrooms are
in the bicot spots where that's I mean
it's it's all worth exploring to kind of
like how far can we translate the
financial doing the bicods to to other
species as well yes
requirements
[Music]
foreign
models for the for the radio versus
versus uh radio versus axial transport
has been developed on the monocots right
so there is tremendous no okay all right
um I'm being okay anyhow but so we've
got so they have developed the transport
water transport models uh to incorporate
the secondary wood growth because that's
not happening in Black Horse uh so
you've got an increased increase
increased surface of the root as the
secondary growth security
yes
absolutely
absolutely yeah so we're we're trying to
accumulate as much of the anatomical
data to kind of implemented that and
then once we've got once we've got the
anatomical data we kind of try to
explore and kind of confirm the models
in different developments as well
yes thank you so much yeah
there's a question about your adopt 247
we're talking about so he said it has a
transmember in domain
and uh
networks because those are already
implicated
yeah so we we did a used hybrid was done
with the protein protein uh structural
event just to make it more soluble okay
so it might be biased and we might be
seeing quite a lot of things there but
yeah we would be expecting some kind of
cost but there's also like a predicted
cost of buying tone so we haven't
validated that it's actually binding
calcium at all
um so that's you know it's it's very
very very hypothetical state
it might be
I think that the trans membrane number
because the transmembrane is not very
specific it doesn't seem like it's
accumulating in a very specific like
subdomain of the of the plasma membrane
and so this lack of specificity I think
it's a part of the protein maturation
rather than being an acting as a part of
the channel
I'd also like the channel I would expect
much more in transferring brain go away
if it's your Channel or some kind of
support
yes uh it seems that uh the findings you
showed us for particularly for the
adults 247 were with sodium chloride
stress and I'm wondering if that's a
sodium effect or is it a plasmatic or
water potential
so we didn't ask the culture of the the
potassium chloride within the plastic
just yet uh just because the effect of
the bath is so so small relatively on
the big system architecture so we need
to do quite a lot of traffic as in order
to get significant results
but we that's definitely in the pipeline
thank you very much for that suggestion
but what I wanted to do is have more
abuse for the buff because right now all
of our findings are based on if you want
which is very dangerous to keep them I
realize that
what was that I'd like to stay nagged
again for not only an excellent seminar
but a delightful one
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu